The brutal Starz series Spartacus
was known for its highly-stylized
gore and its many liberties taken with
historical fact. Lasting four seasons,
it covers one of the greatest rebel
leaders in history, his allies,
and his many, many foes. Here's what the
cast of the popular show is up to now.
Expectations were high for Liam McIntyre when
he stepped in to replace Andy Whitfield as the
main character of Spartacus, but he arguably did
quite well in the titular role. While certainly
different from Whitfield, McIntyre's turn as
Spartacus took the character from a gladiator
slave to a freedom fighter commander — remaining
one of his most famous roles to this day.
"Spread word to every slave yet beneath heel that
even the mighty Republic bleeds when struck!"
In the years since, McIntyre has been quite busy,
both in his career and family life. From
appearing in major TV shows like The Flash,
to providing the voice of JD Fenix in the Gears
of War video game series. In June of 2022,
he and his wife Erin announced on social media
that they are expecting their second child.
Lucy Lawless' Lucretia is one of the early
villains of Spartacus, and the prequel season,
Gods of the Arena. Her unexpected return in
Season 2 was a welcome surprise for many fans,
both of Lawless as an actress, and
of her ruthless Roman aristocrat.
Since her days as the titular heroine in Xena:
Warrior Princess, Lawless has been a major player
in both TV and film. Since Spartacus, she's been
a cast member in series such as Salem and Ash vs.
Evil Dead. Currently, Lawless stars in My Life is
Murder as the private investigator Alexa Crowe,
and provided the voice of Nun-Chuck in the
2022 animated film, Minions: The Rise of Gru.
Even though John Hannah's cruelly ambitious
Batiatus didn't last long on Spartacus,
he is considered a superb early
antagonist. While viewers can
often feel sympathy for the character's plights,
those sentiments are repeatedly dashed upon
seeing how manipulative and cunning Batiatus is.
"It has taken years and the price of blood,
but I at last see you for what you are.
A man that holds no one in esteem beyond himself."
Hannah has appeared in television and movies
since the early 1990s, with his most memorable
role being Jonathan Carnahan, the comic
relief in the Mummy franchise. Hannah
remains incredibly active on screen, starring as
Dr. Jed Bishop in the ongoing series Transplant,
and appearing in shows like Dirk Gently's
Holistic Detective Agency and The Victim.
In a show littered with tragic endings
for most of the central characters,
Crixus — the dependable rival-turned-ally of
Spartacus, portrayed by Manu Bennett — also
meets a grim fate. But Bennett had a fantastic
run with the character up until that point.
Bennett has had many major credits in the
years since Spartacus. Perhaps best known
for playing Deathstroke in the CW series Arrow,
and Azog in Peter Jackson's The Hobbit trilogy.
Recently, Bennett posted on Instagram that he
considers one of the most important roles
of his career being in the 2022 film Muru,
which spotlighted the controversial terror
raids carried out in 2007 by New Zealand police.
The actor admitted that he was
initially hesitant to take on
the role of the oppressor. But after a
heart-to-heart with the lead star — Cliff
Curtis — he was convinced to take the
part. Bennett told the Otago Daily Times,
"They say a hero is only as strong as their
villain, or a protagonist is only as strong
as the antagonist. You have to bring that
energy out, and that's my job as an actor."
Many fans consider Peter Mensah's turn as the
stern and stoic Oenomaus a formidable presence
in Spartacus. Oenomaus is critical, not only
for training Spartacus and the other gladiators,
but for also becoming a key part
of the revolt against the Romans.
"Is this not enough? How many more must die?"
"I would see but one."
Mensah has often featured in shows and movies
with high levels of tension and action,
and that trend continues to this day. The
actor is set to star as Governor Gaddo in Rise,
a thriller centered on a Nigerian princess'
desperate mission to save her sister from the
clutches of Boko Haram. Mensah has also delivered
heart-pounding performances in the 2022 horror
films Hypochondriac and The Devil Conspiracy,
and played the Blind Master in the 2021 movie,
Snake Eyes — the latest installment
of the G.I. Joe film franchise.
Mensah has also continued working
for the small screen since Spartacus,
with his credits including
series like Sleepy Hollow,
as well as playing the villainous Qovas
in Marvel's Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Daniel Feuerriegel's Agron
is one of Spartacus's most
trusted lieutenants. Even though he
is surrounded by doomed characters,
and even witnesses the heartbreaking murder of
his brother Duro at the hands of a Roman guard,
Agron is one of the few rebels who
survives to the end of the series.
In the years since the end of Spartacus,
Feuerriegel took on the role of EJ DiMera in
the popular soap opera, Days of Our Lives,
and appeared in films like Pacific Rim: Uprising,
and the upcoming Heidi: Queen of the Mountain.
Outside of films and TV, Feuerriegel has also
been busy publishing his own graphic novel,
Fractured Shards, telling TV Insider,
"It's been an absolute blast. It's
been phenomenal. You pitch the story,
you write it, and then you see the artist and
colorist do their things [...] It's
such a fun collaborative effort."
To say that Nick E. Tarabay's character,
Ashur, is "sneaky" would certainly be an
understatement. First as a slave and then
as the willing servant of the Romans,
Ashur does whatever it takes to survive,
which includes stabbing anyone who gets
in his way in the back. Yet in the
end, the traitor reaps what he sows,
and is slain by the former slave Naevia
for his horrible crimes against her.
"I will have his life for what he did to me!"
Following the end of the Starz series,
Tarabay had a prominent role as Cotyar
in the sci-fi series The Expanse, as well
as smaller roles in series like Arrow,
and Motherland: Fort Salem. More recently, the
actor has appeared in The Cleaning Lady in 2022,
as well as taking on the recurring part of Eclipso
in the DC series Stargirl. Tarabay's voice can
also be heard in video games like BioWare's
Anthem, and The Dark Pictures: House of Ashes.
The whole Spartacus saga began when our titular
hero was forcefully separated from his lover,
Sura. This tragic romance made it difficult
for actress Katrina Law to enter the series
as the "new woman" in Spartacus' life —
the slave-turned-warrior, Mira. However,
throughout the series, Mira becomes much more
than just the protagonist's lover — playing a
pivotal role supporting the revolt
leader in their fight for freedom.
Following her work on the Starz action drama,
Law has continued a prolific career in film
and television. Her most recognizable role
in recent years is arguably that of special
agent Jessica Knight in NCIS and NCIS: Hawai'i,
but she's also had other major parts like Karen
Beach in the thriller series The Oath, and
the formidable Nyssa al Ghul in DC's Arrow.
While Liam McIntyre replacing Andy Whitfield
wasn't the only actor swap to take the place
on Spartacus, Cynthia Addai-Robinson
stepping in for Lesley-Ann Brandt to
play Naevia for the 2012 Vengeance
season was for altogether different
reasons — with Brandt choosing to leave due
to scheduling conflicts and production delays.
The character Naevia had endured horrific
treatment as a slave in the Roman mines,
and her transformation into a fearless warrior
is fiercely performed by Addai-Robinson.
"There is but single reason Crassus spared my
life. To taunt Spartacus with vision of his end."
Addai-Robinson's other prominent roles
since include Nadine Memphis in the TV
adaptation of Shooter, Ramona Garrity
in the acclaimed crime saga Power,
and Suicide Squad mastermind Amanda Waller
in the Arrowverse. Though Addai-Robinson's
biggest recent role is probably that of Queen
Regent Míriel in Amazon's The Lord of the Rings:
The Rings of Power. When describing
the part to Men's Journal, she said,
"It's complicated. A Regent Queen is not fully
in power yet. Essentially, I'm trying to lead
my people and decide which direction this society
is going to take. It's a fork-in-the-road moment."
As Ilithyia, Viva Bianca had a fascinating
role in Spartacus — not just as the wife
of the hero's arch nemesis Glaber,
but also as the possible mother of
Spartacus' child. Whether that
last bit is truth or trickery,
the controversial infant eventually
leads to the Roman noblewoman's downfall.
Bianca has appeared in several productions
after Spartacus, including the popular 2015
holiday film, A Prince for Christmas, but she
has scaled back her on-screen acting in more
recent years. Instead, focusing on producing
and directing the climate crisis documentary
Generation GND. In September of 2022, she
posted on Instagram that she and her family
finally settled in a new home after spending
a good amount of time moving around. She said,
"In the last 2.5 years we moved 6 times
[...] across oceans and state lines.
That's a lot for anyone but especially a
lot [if] you have little people in tow."
Craig Parker's Roman commander Gaius Claudius
Glaber, quickly becomes the despised nemesis of
Spartacus at the beginning of his turbulent saga.
Whereas Spartacus' other early enemy, Batiatus,
pretends to be on the titular character's side,
Glaber acts with open arrogance and contempt
towards the Thracian — even when reaching out
to fight alongside him as a military ally.
"I shall take my leave when Spartacus falls."
"A task long overdue in its completion."
"Yet now within grasp."
After Glaber causes Spartacus to lose
everything — including his freedom and
his wife, Sura — the rebel leader scores
a major victory in his war against the
Romans when he finally gets revenge
in the aptly titled Vengeance season.
Following Spartacus, Parker has appeared
in minor roles in many different TV series,
including Yuri in the romantic dramedy Good
Trouble and the 2018 revival of Charmed. But
his biggest roles since Spartacus are arguably as
Stéphane Narcisse in the historical drama Reign,
and Guy Warner in the New Zealand soap
opera, Shortland Street. The actor is also
cast in the upcoming thriller A Social Contract
alongside Lord of the Rings alumni, Sean Astin.
When the status of Spartacus was uncertain due to
the health concerns of lead star Andy Whitfield,
Dustin Clare stepped in to become the main
character, Gannicus, in the prequel season,
Gods of the Arena. Gannicus was popular enough to
return in later seasons and join the slave revolt
against the Romans, using his legendary fighting
skills as a gladiator to devastating effect.
Clare has been a TV star for some time
and continues to feature in many different
productions to this day. Most recently, the actor
played a major part in the series Surviving Summer
as Thommo Gibson, and the character George
Michael in the 2022 drama film, Seriously Red.
Beginning in Spartacus: Vengeance, actress
Ellen Hollman plays the formidable Germanic
warrior Saxa, who joins the slave revolt
after being freed by Spartacus and Agron.
As part of the rebel forces, Saxa
fights valiantly and eventually
forms a complicated yet strong bond with
Gannicus, making it all the more painful
for the ex-gladiator when she tragically dies
in his arms during a battle with the Romans.
The character may have met
a tragic end on Spartacus,
but the part led Hollman to a substantial
career in both TV and film. She's earned
credits on major shows, including Lethal
Weapon, Into the Badlands, NCIS, and NCIS:
New Orleans. In film, Hollman recently appeared
in The Matrix Resurrections as the character Echo.
Nasir — played by Pana Hema Taylor —
is a later addition to the rebel cause,
joining the cast in Spartacus: Vengeance.
He quickly becomes one of the rebellion's
most ardent supporters, though he
initially has no idea how to fight,
and even opposes Spartacus. However,
our titular hero chooses to train him,
and from then on, Nasir is extremely devoted
to the war effort. He is seemingly rewarded by
the gods for that devotion, getting to live
his remaining days with his lover, Agron.
Taylor has mostly worked on projects in his
native New Zealand since the end of Spartacus,
including major roles in Dirty Laundry and The
Brokenwood Mysteries. His most notable role since
Nasir may be that of Bert Thompson in Westside —
appearing in 49 episodes of the series since 2015.